on this Friday night a new crisis at
another Ontario care home the corona
virus infects the facility leaving
workers fed up and residents abandoned
everyone knew it could happen and then
then when it did it was it was quite
gut-wrenching the growing challenges for
all these facilities across Canada
Canada's political leaders prepare for
post pandemic life
we need eventually to restart the
economy and new questions about police
enforcing quarantines a loose strategy
with no lockdown if you couldn't stay on
this level I think we are really going
in the right direction
Sweden's controversial kovat 19 plan and
no longer in the clear the fresh fears
for coronavirus patients who thought
they recovered
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
Robin Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
lots of developments to get to on this
Friday but we begin with the devastating
impact of this pandemic on Canada's most
vulnerable people across the country
hundreds of long-term care facilities
have been hit by outbreaks one home for
people with disabilities in Ontario says
it's in crisis mode after declaring an
outbreak staff reportedly walked off the
job last night after hearing workers and
residents had tested positive now the
home is struggling to feed and care for
the people who live there it's unfair to
our you know to our residents to not get
the care they need right now where we
are caring for them and just to be clear
everyone is in their rooms and we are we
are looking after them but it is we need
more we can't it's not sustainable what
we're doing care homes across Canada are
desperate for staff during the Cova 19
outbreak there was a severe shortage of
workers even before the corona virus hit
and those who are working in these
facilities face a grim battle while
trying to protect the residents from
infection they're doing their best to
save themselves and hundreds of Canadian
families are dealing with their own
dilemma take their loved ones out of
care homes or leave them inside and hope
they'll be spared
Ross Lord has our top story tonight
after kovat 19 broke out at this Markham
Ontario home for disabled adults some
unionized staff walked off the job
managers are scrambling to find
replacements so the homes 42 residents
aren't abandoned a number of residents
and staff tested positive for the virus
causing panic once we shared it was
positive we had stuff in the room decide
they couldn't stay and ultimately last
night was a very sickening feeling
because we have 42 the most vulnerable I
can't impress upon you how vulnerable
are our residents our Markham's mayor
has made a public plea for anyone who
can provide personal protective
equipment so the outbreak doesn't become
even worse the an tario government is
offering what assurances it can over an
uncontrollable situation well we'll make
sure we get
or staff in there supporting the
residents but I'll pass this over to the
Minister of Health we need to make sure
that any of them exhibiting kovat 19
symptoms are going to be properly cared
for
we're going to need to put them into
self isolation and make sure that they
get the care that they expect and
deserve outbreaks and care homes account
for the majority of covered related
deaths in BC and roughly half of all
deaths from the virus in Ontario and
Quebec leaving families trying to
protect their loved ones I've lost 1/3
to code 19 as it is we'll deal with it
when it comes the Prime Minister
continues to offer support to health
care workers who are risking their own
lives and increasingly becoming infected
but we also need them to know that we
have their back as they dawn their
protective gear as they go into battle
against this virus for the rest of us we
need to make sure they're getting all
the support they need because they are
the ones that are going to save
Canadians the union that represents many
nursing home workers is not convinced
the nursing home industry hopes measures
like mandatory masking of residents and
staff will limit the virus
the primary objective obviously was to
keep the disease out of the homes and
out of our care facilities but once it
in we have to take all measures then to
manage it down back in Markham emergency
staffing is in place the home's owner
participation house says it's doing
everything it can to prevent further
spread of the virus
Ross Lord Global News in Canada more
than 560 people have died of Cova 19 and
many of them are linked to long-term
care facilities here's a look at the
numbers today almost 1,400 new cases
have been reported across the country
Quebec saw the biggest jump 765 new
cases Ontario's numbers are also going
up it reported 478 new cases today
sending the provinces total surging past
6,000 overall in Canada there are
now more than 22,000 confirmed cases the
number of confirmed cases is growing
inside federal prisons at one in DC a
lockdown is in place after at least 23
inmates
tested positive the mission institution
tested the inmates after they developed
flu-like symptoms the facility is still
waiting on test results from more than a
dozen other inmates at least three
prison guards have also tested positive
the medium security prison-- has the
highest number of confirmed kovat 19
cases at a federal facility more than 50
cases have been confirmed at prisons
across Canada Canada's public health
officer is sending a warning to
Canadians during this Easter long
weekend she says now is not the time to
give up physical distancing this year
has got to be all about the staycation
for the nation the choice of where to be
home in your bubble with your existing
household members only has never been
clearer there is no choice but to plank
the curve then crush it the Prime
Minister has warned life won't get back
to normal anytime soon but as Michael
couture explains some leaders at the
provincial level are sounding more
optimistic even talking about the path
to recovery we need eventually to
restart the economy and give hope to the
population on the eve of Easter Quebec
premier is already talking about
resurrecting his provinces economy
claiming Quebec is approaching the peak
of the pandemic class while ago isn't
ruling out bringing back schools by May
4th because everyone is following health
recommendations even himself we can be
proud of ourselves we're doing
everything we can
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau agrees
with Legault however he believes easing
some of the health measures is months
not weeks away
adding projections show the end of the
first wave of kovat 19 will come in the
summer at that point we will be able to
talk about loosening up some of the
rules that are in place looking at
particular sectors where
people can go back to work legislation
to keep people on payrolls is expected
to pass tomorrow during a special
sitting of both the House of Commons and
Senate the wage subsidy program is part
of the largest economic measures Canada
has seen since World War two other
historic moves being considered include
using the sweeping emergencies Act to
allow the federal government to control
movement of people and redirect medical
supplies to hot spots while it was
discussed during the weekly conference
call with premiers it might not be
necessary we are seeing that the
collaboration the partnership among
provinces and territories and the way
we're moving forward on this means that
we might not ever have to use the
emergencies act and that would be our
preference Ontario Premier Doug Ford
doesn't think the act is needed
particularly to enforce stricter
physical distancing even though the
mayor of Toronto says officers are
patrolling parts this long weekend let's
try to avoid getting a fine everyone
knows what we need to do and we're just
asking people to make sure that they
stay home with their loved ones and Mike
police will also be out enforcing an
order under the quarantine act which
requires everyone arriving in Canada to
stay home for 14 days how are they
planning to do this well Robin they're
dispatching the RCMP if public health
officials can't reach someone who's
supposed to be in self isolation or
quarantine by phone text or email you
could have the Mounties show up at your
home failing to comply with a quarantine
order could mean a million dollar fine
and if it's believed you've put others
at risk by being out and about the
maximum jail time is three years it's a
clear sign that they want people to take
this seriously Robin
Mike Lakota tour in Ottawa thanks Mike
in the United States government
documents show there is no way the
lockdown is close to ending yesterday
alone nearly 1,900 people died tonight
there are more than 480,000 confirmed
cases of Cova 19 in the US and more than
18,000 people are dead but as Jackson
prosecco reports the president insists
the economy will be up and running by
the
in New York there's no end to the
sadness bodies are taken to temporary
morgues outside hospitals that are
filled to capacity after another day
with an unthinkably high number of
deaths and more mixed news to use an
overused term we are cautiously
optimistic that we are slowing the
infection rate that's what the numbers
say there were nearly 10,000 new cases
reported in the state in 24 hours but
hospitalizations have leveled off and
for the first time in weeks
more people were discharged from the ICU
than admitted to it it's really about
the encouraging signs that we see but as
encouraging as they are we have not
reached the peak across the u.s. there's
still an alarming surge in case numbers
in new hot spots New Jersey and
Pennsylvania are seeing their numbers
rise dramatically raising deep
uncertainty about when life could return
to normal in the US when we decide at a
proper time when we're going to be
relaxing some of the restrictions
there's no doubt you're gonna see cases
I would be so surprised if we did not
president Donald Trump has suggested
he'd like the economy to restart by May
but US government projections obtained
by the New York Times suggest fatalities
would spike if stay at home orders were
lifted after just 30 days there remains
a shortage of kovat 19 testing needed to
allow a return to regular life we are
doing tremendous testing but you'll know
you're gonna know before anybody because
you're gonna see nobody's getting sick
anymore it will be gone and it won't be
that much longer that requires getting
the crisis under control in a sick twist
of irony some of America's private
hospitals have started to layoff doctors
and nurses in the middle of the pandemic
blaming losses suffered after elective
surgeries were cancelled to make room
for coronavirus patients Jackson Proust
co Global News Washington
an unprecedented Good Friday Mass coming
up how the Pope was forced to mark the
occasion plus another devastating
diagnosis
for some coronavirus patients
there was another grim pandemic
milestone today the number of deaths
worldwide from Cova 19 has now passed a
hundred thousand cases are also climbing
with more than 1.6 million infected
Italy still has the highest number of
fatalities more than 18,000 people have
died in that country now there are signs
tonight that Italy and Spain have passed
the peak of the pandemic but it's a very
different story in the UK and France
which are now witnessing their worst
ways of covin 19 since the virus hit
Redmond Shannon reports politely
policing a pandemic a London officer
asks people to go home if they are not
visibly exercising enforcing the rules
here is getting more difficult as the
spring weather improves even as the
death toll soars of those who've
contracted the virus
8950 eight have sadly died an increase
of 980 since yesterday in Ireland the
national lockdown has been extended
until May 5th and police are out to
block any Easter getaway plans
a journey to a holiday home is not the
social journey we will be able to turn
about
police in France are using humour to
convince people to stay home the message
the couch should be as far as you go
this weekend
in Germany the death rate among those
infected is distinctly lower than in
other parts of Europeans this group of
worshipers gathered for a special drive
in Good Friday mass praying for the
victims and their families and in the
Vatican a good Friday Mass like no other
hope Francis addressing an almost empty
st. Peter's Basilica Italy remains the
country worst affected by the pandemic
this year only the Pope was permitted to
kiss the crucifix a solemn moment and
another reminder of how this crisis has
touched almost every aspect of life
Redman Shannon Global News London
still ahead comparing the pandemic plans
in two countries where one isn't in
lockdown
you are watching global national here in
Canada and around the world governments
are urging their citizens to stay home
but there is one country that's taking a
very different approach to covin 19
restaurants schools and playgrounds
remain open in Sweden that strategy is
controversial and as Eric Sorenson
explains it's now being tested is there
another way while countries the world
over have shut down Sweden has kept its
schools open and its businesses people
are keeping a distance but they are out
about that thought for Gotham they look
at the streets as this couple people are
out and about and happy Swedes have been
told to look out for the elderly stay at
home if you're sick and work at home if
you can
Swedish chief epidemiologist message
very very clearly and it was also had
quite an impact if you look at the
streets in Stockholm but Sweden has not
ordered a lockdown this hairdresser was
as busy as ever so much I hope she says
they don't do what they've done in
Denmark Denmark is linked by bridge to
Sweden it was among the first European
countries to close its borders and its
schools a bit like a nightmare business
for this Danish hairdresser and
throughout Copenhagen vanished though he
supports the strong measures we trust
like the the government and we believe
in that and we think actually they are
doing a good job who is doing a good job
that's the question all countries are
asking for Sweden and Denmark the number
of kovat 19 deaths was fairly equivalent
at first but then Sweden saw a surge in
April here in Canada the pandemic came a
little bit later but again the numbers
were about the same in the beginning but
then that unsettling increase in Sweden
far outpaced the number of deaths in
this country Canada is more like the
Danish model people went home and
epidemiologists here insist
half-measures won't work the only way
that we're gonna continue to slow down
the spread of the virus as all of us
kind of have to put it together and all
of us have to do our part
there is now nervousness in Sweden cool
with me thumb the king and a rare
address suggested Swedes stay home this
Easter and hundreds of academics signed
a letter to government calling for
tougher
it's extreme measurements that are need
to be taken before you can get control
over this virus but Sweden is not
changing course yet of course we're
suffering
everybody in the world is suffering
right now but it's working and this we
just have carries delivering results
just as good as they ever done and now
Denmark is looking to ease up and reopen
it schools right after Easter deeply a
mosque
Eva gleaned it it's a bit like walking a
tightrope says the Danish Prime Minister
one cautious step at a time
Kevi Finland as countries like Canada
look ahead there may be simple changes
or hard lessons to learn from
Scandinavia Eric Sorenson Global News
Toronto South Korea says 91 people who
recovered from covin 19 have again
tested positive the director of the
Korea Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention believes the virus may have
been reactivated
rather than patients being reinfected
this heightens fears of a potential
second wave doctors around the world are
hopeful people will build an immunity to
Cova 19 after recovering Kongo has at
least two cases of kovat 19 but now it
has even more to worry about the World
Health Organization says a new case of
the Ebola virus has been confirmed in
eastern Congo the news comes just three
days before the country was expected to
declare an end to that outbreak the new
case was confirmed in Beni the epicenter
of the second deadliest Ebola outbreak
in history the country had gone more
than 40 days without a case since August
of 2018 more than 2,000 people have died
from Ebola should they stay or should
they go up next why some Canadians are
choosing not to come home
many families within Canada will be
spending this holiday weekend apart but
there is an even greater distance for
those who are overseas the government
says three hundred and sixty-seven
thousand Canadians are out of the
country right now Global Affairs reports
it fielded more than 1400 phone calls
and over 1500 emails on Wednesday alone
from Canadians wanting to return but as
Mike delay reports some believes staying
put is the safest choice alexis ran seer
didn't debate long about returning to
Canada once kovat 19 started to spread
she lives happily with her boyfriend in
England and as an occupational therapist
at a large Hospital she's on the front
lines every day there are over 350
thousand Canadians living or traveling
abroad right now while the lure of
family is strong
most are staying where they're at Kevin
Kay nurse has built a life in Germany a
country considered ahead of the curve in
dealing with the pandemic far better he
believes I think Canada I did still feel
it was safer and more comfortable to
stay here then come back home to Canada
that sentiment was echoed again and
again with the Canadians we spoke with
Leora wolfmann points to her friends in
Toronto were still going to parties so
it's just not looking at our state in
Austria where she's living on a skilled
immigrant visa small businesses and
restaurants are preparing to reopen
after to very strict months it's hard
not being able to see my friends anyway
my boyfriend and almost a month actually
Justine Beaulieu was on a life-changing
trip through the Pacific Rim when Canada
was getting familiar with the terms
isolation and a social distancing
complicating matters for her in Cambodia
is the political situation martial law
could be declared any day which she
hopes won't affect her since she's found
work on a remote island
of foreigners now bars and restaurants
won't let foreigners and it's mandatory
for you to wear a mask in public in the
big cities for now she'll watch the
Cambodian situation unfold and stay in
paradise while waiting for Koba 19 to
clear up back home considering the
isolation alternative in Canada she's
not in a bad place
Micro Lake Global News Toronto and that
is global national for this Friday I'm
Robin Gill as we keep you informed about
Cova 19 Donna Friesen will be hosting a
special program on Sunday evenings
it's called coronavirus the new reality
and it starts this Sunday at 7 p.m.
tonight we leave you with a poignant
moment at notre-dame Cathedral in France
still under construction from last
year's fire the Archbishop held a small
Good Friday service only seven priests
were allowed to join thank you for
watching we hope to see you back here
tomorrow good night
[Music]